at just three years old a young boy's
family determined he was a girl before
he could even write by the age of seven
he began social transitioning in puberty
blockers and at the point of adulthood
Jazz Jennings is now yearning for the
male experience I just want to feel like
myself like that's it I don't care all I
want is to be happy and feel like me and
I don't feel like we ever yeah and
honestly it's heartbreaking that this
kid has done irreparable damage to his
body with the mom guiding this thing
leading this thing it's funny you look
at the family dynamics of the kids that
are transitioning and it's almost always
the women that are pushing it it's
either you know the woman pushing it
with a super simpy guy or a single
mother